so I've recently come out with a couple
videos talking about how we're getting
$44,000 a week in production on this
vegetable farm and in this video I want
to explain a little bit about our yields
that we're harvesting every week to get
to that
$44,000 I think that'll kind of clear up
uh any confusion you get from that
because just the number could mean a lot
of different things but I want to really
explain how much food we're really
producing on a half an acre of land
which is Tiny amount of land you know
you could do a half an acre of
production in Chicago downtown in in the
city of Chicago you know that's not a
lot of land so um I'm going to go over
that today I'm going to go over our core
crops that are producing those kinds of
numbers and some of the crops that
produce less um and the point I'm making
with this video is not to brag or
anything because I think eventually that
number is going to be a lot bigger for
our farm but once we expand because
eventually we're going to be doing one
to one and a half acres of
production but the point I'm making here
is that you can grow a lot of food on a
small land base and make a living or
grow food for your family and I do offer
a gardening course called gardening 101
the link is in the description where I'm
teaching
you the similar techniques that I use on
this Farm to use in your backyard and
grow a truckload of food for your family
on a couple hundred square feet of land
you know you don't need a lot of land to
do this kind of production
so on every bed that you see behind me
we're trying to get two crops a year in
the field some of the crops grow so big
and bulky that we don't really need to
get two crops to make money and produce
amount of food like this celery is an
example this celery is going to be
almost double the size dies by the time
we Harvest it and it'll be worth at
least $5 each um so we don't need to get
two crops for that but most of the other
crops you see behind me like these
carrots um they're the second crop this
is a fall crop so the technique that I'm
talking about is growing really high
yield crops and growing multiple crops
in the same space if possible um so both
of those things combined is how we get
to $4,000 a week on a half an acre of
production so let's get into it and
highly encourage you to check out that
gardening course in the description it's
a game changer um you'll be able to grow
$1,200 worth of food in 200 square feet
with the techniques I talk about in that
course so check it out and let's get
into the
video okay so you could probably take a
guess what about what I'm going to talk
about next and that is tomatoes so
tomatoes are one of the most profitable
crops that we
grow on the farm and
uh I guess I should actually explain
that a little more it's not exactly
about profit that they bring in but the
yield that they bring in in this small
amount of space is incredible so these
are our granadero paste tomatoes and
they are just exploding this year it's
the best crop I've ever had and
um we're
getting we're not just growing paste
we're growing paste beef steak heirloom
and cherry tomatoes throughout the farm
um we've got one this is our second crop
right now the first crop is still
producing really well um that we planted
back in April this crop we planted late
May and they're just exploding right now
we're in full tomato production right
now we're doing 3 to 400 pounds of
tomatoes per week that's a lot and it's
the most I've ever done and
um that
yield is uh for indeterminate tomatoes
so we're getting that every week and
we've been getting about two to 250
every week since like Fourth of July and
it just exploded once we had the second
crop come in so that's between all four
different kinds but the paste tomatoes
are really exploding right now as you
could see um and the way we're getting
these yields is these are grafted
tomatoes so we've graphed them onto a
root stock uh back in March and in
February for the first crop so that's a
separate variety of tomato that you
splice onto the variety you want to
produce and that increases yield a lot
if you get the right root stock and
that's really complicated I can't
explain it in this video and that's in
that farm course that I've talked about
in the past and it's very hard to do I'm
not going to lie I've screwed it up many
times and I've I got a pretty good
results with it this year and certain
varieties do better but that increases
yields a lot
um so that's a big reason we're getting
the kind of yields we're getting because
there's only about a little over 200
plants in this greenhouse and
about
uh 150 in the other one so it's not a
lot of plants if you know about tomato
production but we get we graft them we
prune the bottom leaves and prune the
suckers so they're all growing uh up a
string and so that increases yields also
in the space that we have they're in a
greenhouse also and then they are um on
drip irrigation as well the drip
irrigation we have on a timer so it's a
completely even watering and we don't
have any problems with splitting or
anything like that so it's a pretty
complicated process but it's worth it to
get those kinds of numbers because right
now we're actually getting $5 a pound
for all those tomatoes and $7 a pound
for Cherries $6 a pound for heirlooms
they're very valuable and climate nobody
can grow them in their Garden here
because it's still below 50° at night so
very few people can have tomatoes in the
western mountains you know again I'm in
Cody Wyoming for anybody who's new so
it's a very mountainous cold climate so
it's very hard to grow tomatoes here so
they're very valuable I'm the only guy
at a big city market with them so it's
pretty easy to get that price and I just
heard that organic Tomatoes at the store
are $5 a pound anyway so I don't feel
bad at all about that price I used to
think that was really expensive um but
after doing the work involved with this
we're pruning these and maintaining them
every week I have employees managing
them it's a very intense process so
that's how we can get those numbers but
when you get that kind of price it's
it's quite a bit of money so that's
almost ,000 a week in tomatoes right now
probably
more uh and it goes up and down depends
on the yield they
ripen uh differently depending on the
weather there's all sorts of factors in
there but those kinds of numbers are
possible with that that amount of space
we're only using a quarter or a little
less than half of the greenhous this
whole Greenhouse for tomatoes so we
still have room to grow all sorts of
other stuff like cucumbers which are the
other ridiculously profitable crop that
we get great numbers on um we're getting
about 200 cucumbers a week right now and
that's actually kind of low for the
amount of plants I'm sure we can get
better um and uh we kind of do the
similar technique with tomatoes we prune
the bottom leaves in the suckers with
those and grow them up a string with
drip tape um similar fertility we're
doing um we fed these crops every week
um with uh alala meal and stuff that
also helps a lot I've noticed um just
after this is like the third year I've
been doing this so it's working really
really well um and so that's those all
that work gets you those kinds of
numbers and if you have really good
employees it doesn't cost that much it
just you you need to do it fast and um
make sure that those F fertilizers
aren't that expensive so it's it becomes
really profitable when you do it that
way um but those two crops are bringing
in the bulk of that $4,000 it's about
$1,500 a week um between the two of
those and it's every single week it's
just like Clockwork um I don't have to
replant another crop it just keeps
coming you know so it's a really nice
crop it's you know we've been getting
those kinds of numbers with tomatoes for
since the 4th of July um and the other
thing about it is it helps sell all the
other crops I'm going to talk about
tomatoes just when you are the only guy
with tomatoes at the market you could
sell almost anything you want so the
other crops I'm about to talk about are
even more profitable um but they're
harder to sell so when you put them
right next to your Tomatoes you can
really make a lot of money that way so
um yeah I think that's kind of helpful
information for people who are kind of
getting into this and learning what kind
of numbers you can make but this is
literally what we're making right at
this minute and I'm sure we can make a
lot more in the future and it's hard the
the big caveat with tomatoes is it takes
a lot of skill to grow like this I mean
I screwed up bad this is the fourth year
I've been growing them like this and it
was not even close to those numbers the
first three there's a lot of little um
intricacies that I can't explain in this
video um that you have to
learn um to get those kinds of numbers
it's not really that easy especially and
it all depends on your climate too so
there's a lot of things I don't want to
make it sound like it's easy to get
those numbers but um that's the numbers
we're getting right now let's move on to
the next
[Music]
crops all right so next thing I'm going
to talk about is uh probably the biggest
money maker of all which is salad greens
and I'm kind of leaving that as a broad
category because it kind of um cut
greens we grow like a bunch of different
kinds of those we grow salanova lettuce
is the biggest um arugula is second
biggest we grow tons of both of these
but we also do tons of spinach miners
lettuce baby kale all cut salad greens
that are Bubble
spun dried and baged and it all pretty
much is the same price just depends on
you know the volume people are buying
but um the price changes a little bit in
the winter when we're you know really
the only person with any fresh produce
that's a little more expensive but
bottom line is uh we're doing about 60
to 80 pounds of salad greens a week
right now and lots of other Farms do way
more numbers than that but just at the
level that we're at in our Market that's
what's working um we're selling about 30
40% of that no actually bought 50% of
that to restaurants um we're slowly
selling more and more at this new market
we're at at full retail price so we're
getting anywhere from s to $10 a pound
on the greens um lots more of them are
starting to go to the Farmers Market at
$10 a pound and that's working really
really well um you know it's taken me a
while to get to that level it's hard to
get a top dollar for them when that's
all you're selling but now that we're
selling at a bigger Market with a lot
more people we can get a better price
and
um the real key with this is the yields
you
know the price is definitely important
but uh you know the more yield you can
sell keyword selling um is where you can
really make the money there so you know
that's that's
providing you know $600 to $800 a week
basically uh and we really want to sell
them more more and more at the uh
Farmers Market but you got to be careful
with it because these are the one
product that definitely have a shelf
life the Salen NOA has an incredible
shelf life for a cut lettuce it probably
lasts 7 to 10 days I've had it last two
weeks and I probably would still sell it
it's incredible I don't know why but it
just when it's growing well it lasts a
really long time but arugula is really
about a week max four to seven days and
most of the other greens don't last as
long spinach lasts a really long time so
you got to make sure you sell it um
because if you cut it and wash it dry it
and it goes bad you got problems and
having a cold room is a really key
detail here that's what's going to
pretty much guarantee that you sell it
all when I used to do this before I had
a cold room it was just so much riskier
if there was a slow Market I lose all
you know half the crop so key detail is
being able to sell it and having a cold
room because once if you have a slow
Market you could at least bring it back
to the cold room and find another Market
but um salad greens are a huge part of
the business um you know and you can't
it's hard in my market to sell these by
themselves you got to sell them with
some kind of draw in the summertime at
least you know so those tomatoes are
what I'm talking about that's a huge
draw
um we're the only people with tomatoes
at the market right now and that's how
we're able to sell you know 40 pounds of
this at full retail price um you know
and uh this particular Salon NOA lettuce
also is just a spectacular product um it
lasts really long time people love it
it's very versatile you can put it on
sandwiches restaurants love it um it's
easy to harvest you know the way we can
get really good yields on this this
whole B when we cut it will probably
yield 50 60 lbs cuz it's going to this
isn't really ready yet this is two two
weeks away and it'll get way bigger um
it'll fill out the bed and it'll be
completely like an ocean of lettuce and
we'll cut it and then it regrows a
slightly lower yield the second cut but
it does grow a second cut and um you'll
get at least 80 pounds per bed that's a
lot of money right there that's if you
do the math on that it's just say you
get $7 a pound I think
that's oh it's seven time eight I'm not
um I don't know I can't remember it off
the top of my head but uh you know
that's
between like6 and $800 you know on in
about 60
days um that's really profitable you
know most crops don't yield that kind of
number so we really try to focus a lot
on this um it's a very expensive seed
there's a lot to Growing lettuce but
once you get good at growing lettuce you
can grow any kind of lettuce and it
works well so that's a really big part
of our business is cut greens so 60 to
80 pounds is part of that $4,000 number
let's move on to the next
crop so these are probably the most
underrated
crop ever these are
peases and uh I started growing these
two years ago and um I just started
actually selling them in the summer this
year I normally was just doing it in the
winter because I figured they'd be
really hard to sell and they are pretty
hard to sell but in when you have a
really good market and you have a draw
crop like tomatoes you could sell a lot
of these and um we also do sunflower
shoots and a couple other micro greens
um but these yield incredible amounts of
shoots per flat this one flat right here
will probably yield 2
lbs just about two pounds of peash
shoots at $16 a pound I could sell at
the market all day and people really
love them after they try them it's great
on a sandwich um it's a great little
rabbit food thing to add to the salad
department on your booth and um you know
we're selling about
eight pounds at the market a week right
now of this in sunflower shoots it's
doing really really well um
so that's a huge Money Maker um we also
sell this to restaurants the restaurants
love to buy it um and uh you know it a
lot of um wholesalers are selling peas
shots anyway and a fancy restaurant's
going to be buying them anyway so your
product is going to be 10 times better
than theirs anyway because it's so fresh
it has a great shelf life it's almost
better than salad greens for some reason
I'm finding it lasts like two weeks no
problem I don't know why you know every
sing you'll find that every single leaf
crop has a different shelf life like
herbs are really weird too certain herbs
will last forever certain ones won't but
shoots are a huge Money Maker we're
doing eight pounds a week at $16 a pound
so that's a huge part of that $4,000 and
we just started really doing well with
that about two weeks ago um but it works
really well when you play it off salad
mix and arugula you can do a two for
nine deal or something where you mix and
match and people will buy one bag of
salad mix one 5 oce bag of this works
great um and uh you know it just it's a
very very good money maker so you got to
try doing it if you are doing any kind
of farming and very easy to produce once
you learn how um and it's I can't
explain how to do it here but there's a
lot of videos out there on how to do it
so highly recommend you try
shoots okay
so you might be able to guess what our
next crop is if you've ever grown them
and that is carrots I've talked about
this in a couple other videos but um we
have
like oh I forgot how many there are 1
two three four five six at least six
beds of carrots growing out in the field
right now and
about eight or so growing in the G green
houses so um that can tell you a little
bit of how important carrots are for the
farm
um we're doing about 150 to 200 Bunches
of carrots a week so one of these beds
gets harvested every week at least
sometimes two um we have enough labor
right now where we can do that it does
take quite a while to harvest carrots
um but carrots are
just they're just like a bombproof crop
because you're always going to sell them
um you know you can either sell them
bunched or you break them down and sell
them into one pound bags and people are
going to buy them um so we grow them a
lot of them fresh Bunch that's the best
way to make money um but you know worst
case scenario you break them down after
the market and sell them bagged and
that's pretty good as well um a lot of
what you see right here is our storage
crop that we're going to sell in the
winter um so there's variety that's
supposed to last six months or something
um so we're going to do like 600 pounds
of those um and sell them slowly over
the winter you know um I don't want to
do too many of that too much of that
because it's pretty hard to harvest 600
pounds in like a day uh and we try to do
it quick because you want to harvest
that before it gets too cold um
otherwise they've turned a little bit
crunchy and weird but they don't store
as well so we'll Harvest those sometime
in October probably this year but
carrots are a big backbone of the farm
and basically all root crops but carrots
are the most important because a lot of
people can grow beets and radishes and
stuff in their Garden but very few grow
carrots well because it's hard to
germinate them and
it's uh that's the number one reason I
think um most people just can't
germinate them or they forget to plant
them again in July you know we plant
them basically every every month we'll
do a big planting uh four or five beds
at a time and do uh you know start that
in like March through July you know and
that's our carrots for the whole year
pretty much I've tried doing a couple
weird plantings in January and that sort
of works um but yeah we do lots and lots
of carrots it's a big back pone of the
farm and so we're doing 150 to 200 bunch
is it depends on the size of the carrots
um how big of our bunches are how good
the germination was on that bed and
sometimes I'll Harvest them before it's
going to yield us 200 bunches because I
need to flip that bed to some other crop
it doesn't really matter if we wait to
get the full yield but you know at a
minimum of $3 a bunch that's a lot of
money that's at least $600 a week more
usually um we do this thing where we're
doing Rainbow carrots and regular
carrots and you get two for six at the
market and that works really well but
you charge $4 for one so you're getting
basically 350 a bunch that way and it
works really well because not everybody
buys two and all sorts of stuff so
carrots are a big part of it we do a
fair amount of Beats radishes probably
about the same amount in those three
crops beets radishes and green onions um
a week but our yields on those have not
been as good as I want them to be um
mostly that's just because of just stuff
going wrong and I don't really try that
hard on Beats because they don't make
that much money um they're a lot harder
to sell also carrots just I'll sell
three to one on Beats
um you know people don't get as excited
about Beats radishes have been very good
but they don't grow well in the summer I
can't get them to produce well when the
flea beetles are going crazy and it's
hot so I wish I could grow more radishes
I think next year I will be able to but
um so that's a huge part of that number
two let's move on to the next crop
all right so herbs in general are
um a huge part of our business now um
slowly built that into the business
because it is hard to sell them on their
own but we're selling a lot to
restaurants right now and a lot at the
farmers market so right now we're only
doing parsley cilantro and Dill and
they're all kind of of growing roughly
the same and bunched the same priced the
same we're doing about $3 a bunch for
roughly a 4 o Bunch but sometimes it's 6
oun or8 ounces depending on what's going
on but um these are really profitable
crops I mean this one B of parsley will
probably bring in
$800 and that's because we're going to
harvest it at least twice and there's
going to
be probably 300
something bunches coming out of here um
and uh it might be a little less than
800 actually because this one won't uh
go as long but that first bed we had did
at least $1,000 because we harvested it
like three times parsley comes back
again and again and again and um you
know it's really valuable at a market
like mine because you're if you're the
only guy with it people want that and if
it's really fresh you they get a big
bunch that looks way better than the old
stuff at the store it's a huge huge
Money Maker you just got to have a cold
room and you know be able to store it um
and this one has a great shelf life um
cilantro and Dill which is what you see
behind me um we do a lot of that as well
that's probably even more profitable but
well not quite because it's just you
have to plant that so much more often
partially you plant it once and it just
keeps going but the cilantro and Dill
will bolt but we're getting at least two
crops out of that each bed and it's just
a truckload we're selling a lot of those
to restaurants and the cilantro is just
going like hot cakes at the market
because people are making salsa with the
tomatoes um so we're doing 150 to 200
Bunches of of herbs per week right now
between the three of those crops um at
between two to $3 a bunch you know
depending on who's buying it so that's a
huge part of that number I anticipate
we'll be doing at least 500 bunches a
week soon um not not this year but next
year um because the Market's just going
to keep as our production of things like
tomatoes and those draw crops increase
and our reputation increases we'll just
sell more we'll sell more the
restaurants we're going to also start
doing perennial herbs like oregano
Rosemary stuff like that you could
charge more for those um and they all
herbs grow back so you get at least two
cuts per per bed and um it's it's not a
super sexy crop you know it's not G but
once you get people into it they're
going to come back to your booth just to
buy those like deal people I have a lot
of Eastern European customers that are
coming back just to buy deal and our
deal looks so much better than most deal
at the market because it doesn't go to
seed it's always fresh we plant it all
the time to keep it that way but it's
worth it because of the amount of
production you can get and yield so um
really big part of our business you know
that's uh what is that you know $500 to
$600 a week just in those crops and um
we did it terrible with basil this year
basil is another huge Money Maker but um
I just didn't do a very good job of
growing the plants this year so they're
really behind and not growing well but
basil is even more money so herbs are
just a big big part of making a lot of
money in a small space so let's move on
to the next
crops okay last but definitely not least
is um what I'm calling miscellaneous
crops which is like a lot of different
crops but um they all we kind of sell
them all the same they're all about like
three to four dollar per
unit um and we're doing 250 to 300 of
those units per week on between all the
different stuff you know it depends on
the week so like cabbage was really hot
the last couple weeks we're almost done
with that that was three a unit we're
doing 50 60 heads of those a week head
lettuce 50 60 heads of those a week
celery um that's just going to start
coming on in a couple weeks um we're
actually doing Bunch celery right now we
just started that I just did a hundred
Bunches of those today um and those were
selling at $4 a bunch celery is a very
profitable crop because nobody grows it
and it's delicious tastes so much better
than the store organic celery right now
is $4 a pound or something right now at
the store so it's like exactly the same
as the store but Whitey years better um
celery is a really good one um it takes
forever to grow but once you have it and
people have tried it it's it's a big
money maker because you could charge a
lot for it people who are juicing are
going to buy a truckload of it because
it's actually really cheap for juice
because it's like 100% juice and the
juice quality is off the charts so um
saler is one of my favorites um we sell
we're trying it as head full head and
bunched this year the bunching you can
actually pick we're going to get at
least two crops out of that batch um if
you plant it early enough you could get
three you just take the outer stems and
then it regrows from the center um big
big money maker um so between those all
those it's like $1,000 dollar a week in
those miscellaneous crops and that means
that's including kale chard um stuff
like that you know so we try and
incorporate a lot of those to add
variety to the table we're growing 25
different crops right now um I don't
know if that's going to change a whole
lot in the future and we might go up to
40 maybe a maximum but um there's just
this there's a I don't want to do too
much variety because it gets hard each
crop is a definitely a skill set in
growing I'd say actually throughout the
year we do probably grow about 4
different crops but right now it's about
25 that we're actually harvesting that's
including stuff like summer squash and
zucchini but all those crops add up to
money um at your Market table and so um
so between all of the crops I've talked
about in this video that's where we're
getting the average of $4,000 a week and
last week was almost five this week will
be probably close to five and then it'll
start to go down again so it really
depends on what's going on you know
we're going to harvest shallots soon and
that's going to be that'll make it like
6,000 but that's something we sell
throughout the year and when I say 4,000
a week it doesn't necessarily mean we're
selling that every week although right
now we pretty much are um some of it we
store and sell later like carrots bagged
will sell later if we have a bumper crop
we could stretch that a little bit
because we have a cold room stuff like
cabbage also if I needed to harvest a
whole bed at once I could sell that
months later if I wanted to celery I
could probably sell a month later it's
forever um salad greens we got to sell
that pretty much that week but kale even
you can stretch that for a while so um
we have sold every almost everything
we've grown this year there's a couple
pounds of greens that we didn't sell at
the very beginning before the markets
really picked up but we're selling
everything right now so we are producing
$44,000 a
week almost everything we sell is in
about a $3 portion that's kind of
standard Farmers Market thing the
tomatoes those more just cuz if we
didn't do that we would sell out in an
hour and then everything else would stop
selling you'll notice if you're in that
position that if you sell out of
tomatoes in two hours the last two hours
your sales drop because the draw to your
Boost stops so we are trying to sell it
slow throughout that whole period to
sell out of the salad greens and stuff
and it's working really really well um
right now I don't think we're have any
problem we have so many we'll start
freezing and selling them in the winter
but um and even with tomatoes if you
don't sell them you freeze them and you
could sell them $4 a pound in the winter
and people use them in in stews and
stuff and it works great so you know
that $4,000 a week is just a rough
average um and um it depends I I mean we
could really bump that up if we had
everything going perfectly like I had
planned might have been five but you
know in farming a lot of things go wrong
I'm still pretty young farm and I'm a
young farmer I'm still learning a lot so
I still make mistakes and um things go
wrong so um that's like you know a real
nice solid number for me I'm very happy
with that this year um given the the
size of the farm and again we're a half
an acre Farm I think we have a total of
about 80 50 foot beds that's not that
much 50 foot means 50 feet long 2 and
a2t wide so this this this bed right
here is a 50ft bed of celery that's a
50ft bed of lettuce so um we're doing
that and some of those you know the
tomatoes is like I did a video a long
time ago earlier this year about how
much money you can make in a greenhouse
and I talked about some of the numbers
you can make on one bed of tomatoes one
bed of tomatoes this year for us is
about $2,000 in Revenue at least um and
it depends on you know how early it is
and stuff but
uh those numbers are just numbers you
know it depends on how successful you
are that the weather all sorts of stuff
but Baseline numbers that's what you can
expect if you're good and that's a key
detail you know I I saw those some of
these numbers a long time ago and I got
really excited my first year and I
expected to get them and I didn't like
things just don't work well until you
build your skill set as a grower and um
I'm still at myself so there's a lot of
factors involved and labor is another
Factor too you got to have really good
labor to make all these numbers happen
easily at least and not break your back
um and we do this year I'm very
fortunate that we do um but um this is
just kind of a glimpse of what is
possible because again we're only doing
a half an acre of production um I think
it's pretty incredible to be able to
bring in that kind of Revenue on a half
an acre because lots of places in in the
world have a half an acre to grow on
it's not very much land um especially
with the price of land going up now so
just wanted to put this video out there
because when I first started I looked
for these kinds of numbers like the
yields that uh Farm was getting because
it helps you kind of plan a potential of
uh of your business I think it's it's
helpful to know what other Farms are
accomplishing so you know what's
possible at least um and um there's a
lot of factors to yields and I'm sure my
yields can be a lot better that that you
know I want to get better at growing
more food on a small space every single
year in the same beted and that's how
you can really make money with this and
I know that as as my skills improve that
will be possible but um this is what I'm
accomplishing right now and um you know
hopefully this inspires somebody's out
there to uh you know think twice about
starting a farm or something so hope you
enjoyed that and I will see you in the
next one